le quai de shippagan fourmille de
pêcheurs c'est l'heure des derniers
préparatifs
le décompte est commencé avant le départ
en mer cette année le tiers des 65
pêcheurs de la péninsule acadienne
prennent un nouvel équipement qu'il
jette à l'eau une fois au large à ce
qu'a dit jean des attaches disent quasi
traditionnelle tous alignés les uns à la
suite des autres avec du cordage plombé
afin qu'ils calent on entend le signale
ici qui est lancée du fils acoustique
aux mécanismes de leur téléphone ils
peuvent déverrouiller l'appareil au fond
de l'eau sous l'eau sous la france de la
flottaison le couverte peut maintenant
se déployer et remonter à la surface
aucun cordages verticale est donc
utilisé on prévient que les baleines
noires ne s'y en pêtre une des
principales causes de mortalité du
mammifère
il n'en resterait que 356 doit pas nous
suggérer des solutions comme la pêche
sans combat joue de codage à la colonne
d'eau ont trouvé que c'était aussi gros
calé sur la lune en 2020
dix pêcheurs ont testé l'équipement avec
10 casier de crabes chacun marter noël
estime l'investissement à près de 100
mille dollars par pêcheur le fonds des
pêches couvrait alors 75 % des coûts
mai 2021 sera l'année de décisive 1050
quasi de pêche seront jetés à l'eau il
ya une évolution de dire ça se peut pas
on peut pas faire ça et là aujourd'hui
on est rendu c'est possible faisons le
plus parce que ça se peut ce soit une
solution qui fasse en sorte qu'en plus
cohabitaient que les badénois aléna elle
fait partie du groupe
moi j'ai décidé que oui on va essayer
puis c'est pour le bien d'industrie
c'est tout le monde vos gants ni de tso
ses collègues et lui expérimenteront les
façons de communiquer entre eux de voir
les bouées immergé pour s'assurer que la
pratique et sécuritaire
l'intérêt de pêcher dans les zones
fermées et grands ça devient tellement
difficile tellement stressant à faire
notre métier on commence qui ont des
positions commencé que faut qu'on pense
de pêche à finir parce qu'on sait que
les baleines s'en viennent il faut se
dépêcher faut se dépêcher peut pas juste
éliminé la page
donc c'est important pour sauver
l'espèce mais c'est important aussi de
trouver comment faire pour sauver
l'espèce en gardant les pêcheurs sur un
territoire monte au dessus du col mais
je te dirais que les yeux est en
nationaux des organismes de protection
de la balerme sont certainement arrivé
sur nous du bas dans la communauté
scientifique que l'industrie la pêche
sur 20 ce qui se passe en acadie de
l'autre côté de la frontière ça fait des
années qu'ils se creuse la tête à
trouver une solution qui fonctionne chez
nous on le trouve et puis ça semble bien
fonctionner est ce qu'un succès cette
année pourrait révolutionner tout la
pêche au crabe
peut-être qu'un jour en dehors avant on
pêche avec des lignes verticales
peut-être mais je pense qu'on a quand
même beaucoup